for fans of no man's sky the wait is
coming to an end according to studio
head Shan marae the space faring sandbox
game will be out on jun 21st the news
was delivered during a recent event held
for press which also revealed the
presence of alien npcs and the ability
to learn different languages and trade
among them announced during the 2013 vgx
spike Awards no man's sky will set
players free to roam the universe with
access to 18 quintillion procedurally
generated planets of varying climate and
habitants and challenge the game will
allow players to upgrade their spaceship
suit and weapons as they explore the
universe dealing with alien races and
leaving their mark and uncharted
territories earlier this week Sony may
have accidentally revealed that no man's
sky would cost sixty dollars prompting
some disagreement with the fans as to
the price point and there you have it
last year they told us the game with
launched in June and it looks like we're
getting it in June are you excited for
no man's sky stay tuned to gamespot for
more info as we near launch